I feel like not a lot of people know
that Blackberry is Canadian I didn't
know neither did Glenn wait it's
Canadian oh adults come on now what are
you guys talking about come on now so
like listen I learned a lot about
Blackberry I mean and I learned a lot
about Ontario
so what do you think other people will
learn from black this Blackberry film
about Canada
um do you want to start I wonder that's
probably a better question for Glenn
because because you were the person who
learned things about Canada Jane already
knew this stuff I mean I'd like to think
uh had you ever seen milk in a bag
before
I didn't know what you're talking yeah
so we thought people were handing me
milk in a bag that's right you're one of
the special people who it's already
cupped by the time you're holding it
yeah
the the way the the ways all the
dysfunctions of how the world interacts
with itself and how we all communicate
and all of the problems and the good
stuff but mostly the stuff
um that all all of that stands uh on the
shoulders of what these nerves in
Waterloo did in the late 90s and um so
uh I kind of think that like
historically it's up there with like
Gutenberg Press in terms of just like a
a a sort of
except for nobody will remember their
names and we're still saying the name
Gutenberg although I think Steve had a
lot to do with that Police Academy
restored good honor to the Gutenberg
absolutely a thousand years of bad press
for having it literally yeah
not a thousand not a thousand Gutenberg
Bible was 1453 wasn't it but the Press
was probably yeah okay so close to a
thousand anyway uh that we made
something crazy that the whole world up
and nobody knows it happened right right
cool cool guys are your very normal
questions I'm glad that that's the
takeaway yeah
well what did you learn about Canada
watching I mean I learned to be I mean I
didn't learn too much that I didn't
already know I mean I started this by
saying you learned a lot about Ontario
and I learned some like some some terms
yeah that came from where is it Waterloo
yeah Waterloo so you're from Calgary so
don't judge me but I did move to Toronto
there's a great ice cream place they're
called made by Marcus you've been there
oh yeah you know I've been there yeah
yes I will be there have some ice cream
for me yes I will be so good what's so
special though I'll tell you there's two
things they do that are really unique
one is they use a lot of fresh fruit and
a lot of savory ingredients so like like
like raw lemons and things where you're
like what that'll be horrible when you
taste your life
I believe you're going but I gotta talk
to you because I feel like you're
avoiding this next question which is
that only one of you have actually used
a Blackberry and I'm looking at you Jay
yeah right I'm looking at you it's very
Obsession I used to literally two years
ago two years when I stopped yeah get
out I still have the last one and I
can't throw it out or anything and uh
yeah I miss it I really miss it I I like
nothing better about the iPhone right my
life has not improved one bit I just
miss about it what is it exactly that it
was way easier to use for me I hate
touch screen I hated I like that it
wasn't covered that was distracting
um it had no apps on it yeah the only
thing that's better is I see like now
the group chats of like videos of my
like baby nieces and stuff that stuff's
nice yeah but uh but yeah no I'm just
now I'm just some other another
with every other phone and everybody
else and you can't ping I miss the pink
you know the BBF if you guys used one
you'd know how addictive
yeah all right uh I gotta know because
Matt I feel like you know there was a
lot of influence in Doug's uh you know
Ensemble how much of your own personal
closet did you use a lot 100 a lot yeah
every every single time I've gone to an
event
that or I've gone to film festivals I've
screened the film every time I get there
I've always met with the kind of wow you
dressed as your character in the movie
and it's in such an insulting tone where
it's like why would you do that and I
think you know I was you have the
Genesis wrong I decided I would come to
set wearing the clothes I normally wear
so I wouldn't have to go through
wardrobe makes sense because you spend a
lot of time directing a movie and I
thought I will save time by just wearing
my clothes now it's just a bit Yeah but
unintentionally yeah he's got his
headband yeah
okay so the thing is I feel like you're
kind of like a Blackberry like you do it
all
okay
but and my total has been no but no not
as good as the iPhone right I would
never imply that I just mean in this
film you mean you're writing you're
directing you're starring yes okay yeah
right thank you
yeah all right right so how like what
was the experience like for you wearing
all those hats at once uh you know what
I don't think that it could have been
done any other way especially in terms
of the three of us working together
if I had just been behind the camera I
don't know that the communication
between the three of us would have been
as clear and it was important for me to
in some ways this may sound strange but
to be playing the character with the
least power
because it helped
me direct because it meant that I could
go between a place of having absolutely
no power in in scenes with these guys
where I was absolutely at the bottom of
the totem pole into a situation where I
could be saying okay let's try it like
this like not really barking commands
but but telling them what I wanted to do
and it
I think because these guys are both such
strong personalities it made it easier
for them to uh well work with me yeah
are you saying that because we're
egomaniacs and and I'm saying that in
the nicest way possible had you've been
a powerful character and a powerful
presence on the status I would have been
rejected we would have like rebelled
against you would have been like well I
get to crush him in the scene
I'll take your pathetic ideas but
honestly I think it's something you just
disarmed us so that we would listen to
you it wasn't no it's not it's not bad
yeah but it was on it I thought you were
humoring me